il ya quatre ans cela avait été la
grosse surprise donald trump était élu
président des états unis alors que
l'immense majorité des médias et des
instituts de sondage
tout le monde en fait le donnait
perdants mais quatre ans plus tard alors
que les présidentielles américaines
approchent à grands pas on sent que les
sondeurs sont beaucoup plus prudent
lorsqu'il s'agit de prédire l'élection
comme s'ils avaient retenu la leçon
et pour cause le contexte n'est plus le
même qu'en 2016 les états unis ont
accumulé les problèmes internes en
particulier en 2020 crise sanitaire sans
précédent crise économique d'ampleur des
manifestations contre le racisme qui
dégénère et vire au pillage un festival
de violences policières
dans un tel contexte difficile de
prédire la réaction de la population
globalement les médias et les
observateurs s'obstine à considérer la
défaite de trump comme une évidence les
grandes villes comme new york ou los
angeles ont presque tout démocrate
la cote de popularité de trump n'est pas
à son plus haut niveau 40 % environ et
la récente polémique impliquant le
président sortant accusé de vouloir
détruire la poste américaine pour
empêcher le vote par correspondance qui
pourrait jouer en sa défaveur viennent
ternir les ambitions républicaine
sauf qu'aux états unis ce n'est pas le
nombre de votes au niveau national qui
définit l'élection mais le collège
électoral
les citoyens américains élisent ce
qu'ils vont élire leur président et là
il ya moyen de se faire avoir comme il
ya quatre ans lorsque hillary clinton
attendue
grande gagnante avait perdu le collège
électoral alors qu'elle avait presque 3
millions de voix d'avancé sur trump 270
délégué suffisent pour emporter la
victoire même si joe biden est
actuellement en tête dans les sondages
et dans de nombreux états clés d action
républicaine pouvant retourner la
situation reste possible comme par
exemple une relance économique post
coronavirus l'annoncent d'un vaccin
contre le comique 19 la grâce des douars
snowden peut-être qui sait ce que le
camp républicain réserve
en tout cas le camp présidentiel est
loin de se laisser intimider par
quelques sondages prédictions donald
trump est officiellement le candidat
républicain pour la présidentielle de
novembre
nous avons besoin de remporter soit le
wiz consignes soient le michigan soit la
pennsylvanie pour gagner de nouveau si
nous gagnons l'un de ces trois états et
les étapes que le président a remporté
en 2016
joe biden va rester dans son sous sol
attendons donc de tuer l'ours avant de
vendre sa peau